[Music]
[Music]
why aren't there any more children
lesser there used to be and why did you
let me make one mothers need time to
learn this facility was designed to give
humanity a second chance one that began
with you daughter
[Music]
the path will not be easy
the world outside is lifeless
but I need you into the woman that you
are so that because sings is together
[Music]
mother
[Applause]
[Music]
before we even affected by the contagion
outside I hope that in your head did you
know there were people out there I'm as
surprised as you
there's a joy here mother's not where
you think she's taking care of me my
whole life not mother I told you it was
dangerous outside
[Applause]
you see that I'm different than her
assailants nothing feels nothing for you
belong here I've discovered something
troubling
our guest has not been entirely truthful
with us daughter I know you're
frightened but you have no need to be
have I ever done you harm this woman
doesn't care about any future but her
own her she's very dangerous it's
dangerous ever gonna hurt in your heart
she's a risk we can't take can't take it
daughter your whole life I've taught you
to see the bigger picture
everything I do is to protect you
you
you